these days Halligan lands luxury hotel
is reserved for the technicians of wind
turbines things what's most difficult
are the working hours you generally work
12-hour days when the weather is good so
you're pretty wiped out in the evening
Stefan Skoda gets his assignment for the
day we are accompanying the Siemens team
depending on what kind of a team it is
we're sort of the eyes and ears for our
company
after a few stormy days the weather is
finally mild morning Stefan's job is to
oversee the installation of the wind
turbines
this job can be dangerous we had to take
several training courses including
protection against Falls see survival
and offshore firefighting
today stephanas sending his men up
several turbines the electrical systems
are installed and now the control boxes
have to be mounted believers esteemeth
most of Paranal on whether he consults
with his team about the best way to
distribute their personnel
it's 1:00 p.m. the catamaran from the
mainland arrives carrying tourists today
they include a special delegation
captain I've invited the entire offshore
industry from Germany including managers
and political representatives a boat
ride is part of the experience of
visiting heligoland
but aboard of a lowland under London
yogs Inga the islands mayor has invited
his guests to the town hall the
heligoland errs always vote 5050 I was
voted in with 51% then there was a
referendum it's a very complex issue
complex issues can't always be expressed
in a purely emotional way and how many
are asking what's in it for us will they
take up all the rooms for the tourists
the Islanders are worried about all the
offshore construction workers filling up
Halligan's hotels they're skeptical
about whether they really will bring in
more money than the tourists this man is
asking the tough questions in the local
council each club does is open all I'm
wondering if the hotels that only rent
to offshore workers will have to pay the
tourist tax probably not gorilla and
fell heavily into debt so relax funds
for other areas there really needs to
invest in tourism but at the moment
all the money is going to be offshore
industry you offer almost 8 million
euros for wind energy but the mayor is
sticking to his guns
yeah monitamon town yes ladies and
gentlemen come on a Klingon man seed
money I can see may I please have your
attention it's nice to see you all here
and that you've arrived safely on
heligoland today we're trying to combine
our core business of tourism with
research and offshore wind energy for
heligoland and for Germany the switch to
renewable energy sources using offshore
wind power is a factor for economic
growth and it's our intention to seize
these opportunities
but that's just what has the Islanders
worried will tourists still visit we'll
have more in the next installment